good morning my name is Benjamin
Greenberg and I'm an associate professor
of neurology at the University of Texas
Southwestern in Dallas Texas I'm here
today to talk about a unique b-cell
derived signature of multiple sclerosis
and it's biologic indications I look
forward to an interactive session as you
know you can send questions through the
internet and I'll be answering them at
the end with that mind let me first note
some disclosures to my talk today I've
received consulting piece for a number a
number of companies but the one
important here is Dietetics incorporated
with which I do own equity they have an
exclusive license from the University of
Texas Southwestern for some of the
technology that will be talked about
today the goals of today's talk are to
introduce you to a disease known as
multiple sclerosis for some in the
audience as may be something you're well
familiar with for others this may be a
new clinical entity I'll also discuss
the data we have both within the
University of Texas Southwestern and
what's been published relative to the
role of B cells in the pathogenesis of
multiple sclerosis we'll go on to talk
about the data that's been generated
here at UT Southwestern known as the
antibody gene signature of multiple
sclerosis and go on to more recent work
that's shown the biologic implications
of this signal seen in the spinal fluid
of patients with MS and finally we'll
talk about future directions where we
plan to go with this research and what
you can expect to see out of labs and
collaborators here in Dallas so let's
start with an introduction of multiple
sclerosis some of you in the audience
may not be aware of how this disease
presents and I thought it would be
useful to give you a typical background
of what our patients may experience so
in this situation a 28 year old woman
comes her physician indicating that for
a week she's had pain in her eye and
some blurred vision when the physician
tests ER they find that she does have
reduced visual acuity she used to be
20/20 and maybe now she's 2040 or 2060
and my eye and she indicates every time
she moves her eye at hurts and has an
adult ache around the
when her physician performs an exam the
rest of it is normal they don't find any
other abnormalities but upon questioning
she indicates that a year earlier she
had gone to her doctor indicating that
she was numb from the waist down the
doctor just kind of dismissed it and
said she had pinched nerve and sends her
along her way over on its own over about
eight weeks it resolved and no other
treatment was was needed but now she was
coming in with the vision issues so an
MRI was ordered by her physician and it
revealed multiple abnormalities within
her brain that were consistent with
something called demyelination and it
was based on this and her history of
multiple events over time that she was
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis and
started one of the ten fda-approved
therapies for this chronic condition
this is a pretty typical presentation of
how MS gets diagnosed a lot of times
however people can have atypical
presentations or more unusual
presentations and there's a large
differential diagnosis there are a lot
of things as a neurologist I think about
when a patient like this comes to my
office so multiple sclerosis just to
give you some background is the most
common cause of disability and young
adults especially in the United States
it affects anywhere from three to six
hundred thousand individuals in the US
and probably about one and a half to two
million patients worldwide it's more
prevalent in women than in men it's
about a two to one or even excuse me 3:1
ratio in women to men and it's more
common among those of Northern European
descent usually this gets diagnosed in
people's 20s and 30s it hits individuals
in their prime and often in about I
should say ten percent of cases we can
see the first symptom happen in the
pediatric years and so this is not a
disease exclusively of adults but
definitely the majority of folks are
diagnosed again in their 20s and 30s and
it has a massive cost in the United
States the figures noted here around ten
billion dollars a year are probably on
the conservative side over the last
several years the cost of drug therapy
especially United States has skyrocketed
with the average annual cost being
somewhere between fifty and sixty
thousand dollars per patient per year
for one of the FDA approved therapies
it's making multiple sclerosis one of
the most
expensive conditions in the u.s. at the
same time that the expense has gone up
with these drugs we have found
tremendous efficacy but there are risks
and so we are left in a situation where
a cure diagnosis becomes incredibly
important so that we are only treating
people who actually need the therapy so
here are some of the different symptoms
somebody with multiple sclerosis might
experience as in the case that I
presented this person had vision loss
some people can have double vision where
all of a sudden they say they're seeing
two of things imbalance it can look like
they've had a few too many drinks when
walking down the street they can have
weakness they can have numbness they can
have difficulty walking pain bladder
dysfunction depression cognitive
dysfunction fatigue sexual dysfunction
and for each of our patients they have a
different combination of these various
symptoms for some individuals they start
with vision loss and progress to include
the other symptoms but for others they
may start with just the fatigue and then
develop a numbness later the reason
keeping track of that is important is
because it increases the sense of a
awareness that the differential
diagnosis can be quite difficult there
are a lot of diseases within neurology
that can present with numbness there are
a lot of diseases within neurology that
can present with imbalance or gait
difficulties so when you're that first
physician and you're seeing a patient
with one of these symptoms you don't
know off the bat that they have multiple
sclerosis they could have a whole host
of other conditions and so trying to
sort out what the cause of your patient
symptoms are it can be quite tricky this
is not a new problem we've had this
since the beginning in fact the first
clinical description of multiple
sclerosis probably goes back to the
1400s
there's writings of a Dutch patron saint
of ice skating levena of Schiedam how
you get to be the patron saint of ice
skating I don't know but evidently this
teenage girl experienced a series of
neurologic events that when we look back
in history sounded like a pretty classic
description of multiple sclerosis now
back in her day there were discussions
of demonic possession and all sorts of
things but in the end looking back in
hindsight we feel she had a pretty
classic case of MS unfortunately
even though we've had over 600 years
passed since the Dutch patron saint of
ice-skating suffered these symptoms
often were still in the dark relative to
the explanation in the diagnosis if you
fast-forward to the 1800s Jean Martin
choco did the first clinical pathologic
description of multiple sclerosis so
what he did in frames was analyze
patients clinically you see what their
symptoms were over time and do very
killed for him
careful histories and physicals
documenting what was happening to
patients and throughout his career he
followed his patients to see what the
long-standing implications were what
disabilities did they develop what types
of problems they had but he went further
to look at these patients in a
post-mortem fashion to describe what was
happening at the pathologic level first
in gross terms and also in microscopic
terms and what jean-martin charcot did
was correlate what he was seeing within
the pathologic specimens with what he
had seen within the clinic so that first
clinical pathologic correlation and
indeed what John Martin Charcot saw was
changes within the brain as seen here
a slice of brain with arrows pointing
out the so called plaques of multiple
sclerosis the sclerotic plaques now
you'll note where all of those arrows
are there in a typical distribution of
multiple sclerosis there are around the
ventricles those deep-seated holes in
the middle of the brain where we make
spinal fluid
some of them abut the gray matter that
so-called juxta cortical lesions and
these abnormalities which can be seen
grossly at autopsy correlate sometimes
with the symptoms that patients have but
not always there are some parts of the
brain where if you do arrive one of
these plaques for multiple sclerosis you
will have very reproducible symptoms if
it's along the cortical spinal tract you
lack weakness if it's a long this amount
of sensory track you may have difficulty
with sensation but a lot of these
plaques are not in what are known as
clinically eloquent areas meaning the
symptoms you may have may be
non-existent or extremely vague those
patients can have a large number of
changes in their brain with no symptoms
whatsoever this is not a unique feature
of multiple sclerosis but due to the
we see it quite frequently thus when
somebody comes to me for a diagnosis
often that first symptom they have is
not actually the first attack that
they've had it's just been the first
attack that happened in a clinically
eloquent area sometimes however patients
come with their first attack being in a
clinically eloquent area and we don't
have the evidence of previous attacks
again making diagnosis a little
difficult now back in 1868 jean-martin
charcot with limited resources and
technologies especially compared to
today did an incredible job with the
clinical pathologic description of this
disease and if you go back to his
original writings about the pathology
what he saw under the microscope in
multiple sclerosis it was quite
extraordinary as noted here he said on
histologic sections multiple sclerosis
lesions contain peri vascular
inflammation and demyelination plaques
occur anywhere within the white matter
of the central nervous system and he
noted the most frequently affected areas
including the optic nerves brainstem
cerebellum and spinal cord the lesions
in these locations often correlate to
symptoms and in the cerebral hemispheres
there is a periventricular distribution
of these plaques when there's plaques
however about the cortex the so-called
juxta cortical lesions you can even see
subcortical myelinated nerves being
spared but plaques located near the gray
white the gray matter may extend into
the gray matter so these descriptions of
multiple sclerosis which again happened
150 years ago are incredibly similar to
our descriptions of what we see
pathologically today even with all of
our technologies whether it be imaging
MRI or in a histopathology lab looking
at grow sections of tissue we have not
done a dramatically better job of the
pathologic description of MS we've noted
that this is an inflammatory disorder a
demyelinating disorder but even in the
1860s
Charcot noted that it is not just a
disorder of white matter the gray matter
is involved and the axons which are what
connect the cell bodies to the rest of
the nervous system can be transected in
multiple sclerosis these key features of
MS have been the underpinning of our
advancement of Technology our
advancement of imaging or enhancement of
therapies for 150 years and there have
not been a number
breakthroughs in the pathologic setting
until the last ten years so if you go
back over time and try and sort out what
causes MS what's the biologic
underpinning it's been an interesting
history so if you go back to the 1900s
and ask what was the cause of multiple
sclerosis you'd be told there you
weren't sweating enough so we'd send our
patients home we'd say get into bed pull
the covers up over your head and sweat
for it turns out that that's not true
and it doesn't work if you move to the
19-teens multiple sclerosis was
considered to be a disorder of toxic
exposures and we were told telling our
patients to purge their system but the
1940s we talked about multiple sclerosis
being a disease of poor circulation and
if we just augment circulation things
would be better so we prescribed Pazar
dilators that didn't work it's not until
the 1960s with the immune the world of
immunology really maturing that we first
started to talk about multiple sclerosis
in the setting of an immune system and
we defined it as a allergic reaction and
if you took enough vitamins and
histamines maybe it would help and then
as we move to 2000 you get the first
description of multiple sclerosis I
should say the 1980s all the way through
2000 1970s through 2000 of multiple
sclerosis being an autoimmune condition
with a immune system presumably reacting
against Milan and if we can modulate
that immune system or sometimes even
suppress that immune system we can
prevent the symptoms and the disability
that comes with multiple sclerosis and
this theory an autoimmune reaction
against Milan has driven the field for
the last 30 to 40 years and there are a
couple key features in bed in this
theory that are worth noting the first
is that this is an autoimmune disease
and we're going to move into the actors
within immunology in a moment but the
second is the target of the autoimmune
disease is incredibly important relative
to explaining what we see clinically and
what are the therapeutic options if
indeed this is a disease purely of
antigens within myelin driving the
clinical response then it would take us
down one path relative to developing
prognostics diagnostics and therapeutics
if however the autoimmune attack is
directed against a variety of antigens
if they dramatically change the way we
think about multiples
and we're going to talk about that a
little bit today with our data from V
cell repertoires of MS patients so what
happens clinically in multiple sclerosis
so you have this autoimmune disease
jean-martin charcot saw peri vascular
inflammation lymphocytes around the
blood vessels within the brain you have
demyelination
and you can have damage to the axons
clinically what I see in my multiple
sclerosis Center here in Dallas Texas is
one of four patterns of disease with the
most common being represented at the top
of this graphic known as relapsing
remitting multiple sclerosis and then
relapse remitting multiple sclerosis the
theory is the immune system goes in
causes inflammation and demyelination in
a clinically eloquent area and you get
one of those orange bars which is a
clinical symptom if you think back to
our 28 year old her first bar was the
numbness from the waist down
which got completely dismissed by her
physician as being a pinched nerve her
second bar on this graph would have been
her optic neuritis that visual change
that she had that blurring a vision that
she experienced over a year later
untreated relaxer many multiple
sclerosis patients go on to have future
attacks represented here by each bar but
as you'll notice over time that bar
doesn't go back down to baseline we
don't always recover from the attacks we
have in multiple sclerosis and you can
start to develop disability over time
with each successive attack less
recovery and hence if it there's an
attack that affects your walking you may
not get back to normal walking sometimes
you do but often you don't there are
other versions of multiple sclerosis
however which seem to be linked it leads
pathologically there's a so called
secondary progressive phase of MS which
is designated by the second orange
construct on this graph where patients
start off as relapsed rebidding disease
with attacks at common and recovery that
comes after the attack but after a
period of years it might be a few years
or even fifteen or twenty years the
patient changed into what's called a
secondary progressive state where the
attacks ceased to occur at least
clinically but every year is a little
worse of the year before so called
progression where I may see a patient
this month and they're using a cane but
they come back a year later and they're
using
there's been no intervening attacks this
is the so-called secondary progressive
stage of MS and when untreated up to
half of our patients will go on to have
secondary chronic disease the rarest
versions of the disease are the primary
progressive and progressive relaxing
versions of the disease and primary
progressive there are no relapses that
we ever see but from the beginning every
year is worse than the year before with
a slow progression of symptoms the most
common form of multiple sclerosis is
relapsed permitting and if we're talking
about untreated disease a lot if not the
majority of relapsed or omitting
patients go on to have a secondary
progressive course so the majority of
cases of MS and the majority majority of
research in ms has focused on so-called
relapsed remitting multiple sclerosis
now
here's another way of looking at
relapsed remitting multiple sclerosis
seen here in green is the level of
disability and so there's an individual
and this is clinical this is the person
coming into my clinic so that first
green bar for that 28 year old woman we
discussed would be the numbness from the
waist down and she recovered completely
to it back down to her baseline and then
time goes on and a second event her
optic neuritis occurs and if we do
nothing over years she may have more and
more clinical events and then ultimately
go on perhaps to secondary progressive
disease but what's happening beneath the
surface we can see that in the clinic I
can see that by talking to my patients
and examining the patient's but what's
underlying this and there is a lot of
biology underlying these events I'll
draw your attention now to the orange
bars on this graph notice that there are
many more orange bars events of
inflammation cells going into the brain
causing damage then there are clinical
events and indeed by the time our 28
year old woman had had her first event
of numbness from the waist down she had
had multiple inflammatory events but
they just never occurred in an area that
gave her symptoms or they never reached
a threshold that would cause profound
symptoms so she was unaware of these
inflammatory events now with each of
these inflammatory events there's damage
done there's demyelination and potential
external laws but it's only when it
crosses a certain threshold that were
clinically aware of it the other way to
think about that is it is our clinical
measures of this
disease are insensitive for tracking the
disease and are insensitive for
diagnosing the disease there are lots of
things that can get people's symptoms
and there are also lots of ways to have
damage with no symptoms and so getting a
better handle on what's happening under
the surface beyond what we see in the
clinic is incredibly important the other
thing you'll note here in the shaded
blue is the axonal loss that grows over
time it is this loss of axons that we
think drives progression so you can have
demyelinating events over and over and
over again and have symptoms that come
and go and they will leave damage and
perhaps you may not recover fully but if
I look at the 2030 or four year span of
multiple sclerosis that patients are
used to dealing with their long-term
disability is probably dictated by the
number of axons that cut more than the
amount of myelin content that gets
damaged
thus the secondary progressive phase and
probably the primary progressive phase
of multiple sclerosis is dictated by
that act so no loss moreso than damage
to myelin
that's a theory but there's a lot of
data to support it why is that important
well again it goes back to the
underlying theory of multiple sclerosis
being an autoimmune disease that target
smiling we do have evidence to say
that's true but if there is an
autoimmune if there is no component to
the autoimmune profile that targets the
axons the neurons glial cells leading to
an accentuated external loss this would
be incredibly important for us to
understand to get a handle on the
difference between the relapses that
patients have and the progression and
external loss that patients have so as
you keep this in mind it will play a
role in what we find within the b-cell
repertoires and multiple sclerosis now
what is that peri vascular inflammation
so the relapses that we see are probably
dictated by these little blue cells
lymphocytes we don't see neutrophils we
don't see eosinophils we don't see
basophils in the brains of multiple
sclerosis patients hardly ever if at all
but we do see this Perry vascular
inflammation these little blue cells
lymphocytes tnb cells around blood
vessels that then will spread out in a
concentric ring around that blood vessel
causing demyelination and that plaque
that star that jean-martin charcot saw
150 years ago
luckily these days we have a less
invasive way than biopsy or autopsy for
tracking the inflammation within
multiple sclerosis and is seen on the
screen you see a typical t1-weighted
post gadolinium MRI what that sentence
means is we're getting a certain picture
of the brain we're injecting contrast in
this case gadolinium and anywhere that
there's been a breakdown of the
blood-brain barrier
perhaps by Perry vascular inflammation
you see that white circle that so-called
enhancement the accumulation of contrast
highlighting that there's active
inflammation in that part of the brain
and this correlates with active disease
we have done multiple studies comparing
tissue due to what we saw in MRI and
what patients experience and when you
look in these issues almost always you
will see active inflammation within MRIs
however you can also find a variety of
other findings it's not just good for
seeing active disease but you can see
the burden of disease that's occurred
over time so one example on the top left
of here is the so-called
t2 hyperintensity and you can see a
couple of white spots within the brain
that show you where old scars have
occurred and it can happen in the stream
or hemispheres it can happen in the
brain stem the spinal cord but in the
lower left corner of this slide you'll
see that this patient has a more
significant burden of disease a lot of
periventricular lesions and they are
starting to have atrophy of the brain
something that we see accelerated with
in multiple sclerosis because of those
lost axons we see that the brain shrinks
over time unfortunately for all of us we
have brain shrinkage as we get over
older but in multiple sclerosis this is
accelerated and it's something that
leads or at least I should say it
correlates with the level of disability
that patients have over time so what's
happening within the peri vascular
inflammation
you can't give a talk with that in
multiple sclerosis without having a very
busy slide such as this showing all the
different actors within the central
nervous system including
oligodendrocytes neurons astrocytes
microglial cells myelinated axons and
also show any evidence that there is an
interplay between the immune system both
the innate and adaptive immune system
within the brain and the adaptive immune
system circulating throughout the body
heads the lymphocytes have to transgress
across a blood vessel
to diet that east across that blood
vessel and lead to inflammation within
the brain for angleman or a spinal cord
Brinkman to lead to demyelination both T
and B cells have data to suggest they're
involved but it's worth noting that for
20-30 years
this was wholly thought of as a T cell
disease as a CD form perhaps cd8
mediated disease and it was a great way
to start fistfights at meetings twenty
years ago talking about which was more
important that cd4 T cell or the cd8 T
cell for propagating the disease but
what about the B cells and multiple
sclerosis so there's a lot of data to
suggest that we should consider multiple
sclerosis as a B cell disease and it's
worth noting that this would be heresy
twenty years ago it was thought of as
the B cells being peripherally involved
in multiple sclerosis but not a central
actor within the disease but what's the
data to suggest that this may not be the
case well if you look at patients who
have not developed clinical MS yet if
you look in that pre onset area there is
a couple pieces of data there's the data
about epstein-barr infection in vitamin
D deficiency being risk factors for
developing multiple sclerosis and both
of these things epstein-barr infection
and vitamin D deficiency have profound
impacts on B cell biology very
circumstantial evidence and not enough
to convince a jury so say but there's
evidence throughout the course of
disease for example when you look at
somebody's first clinical event a
so-called clinically isolated syndrome
you can find that peripheral B cells
with that 28 year old who had the
numbness from the waist down had higher
levels of expression of certain subunits
that are responsible for getting in
across the blood-brain barrier the so
called VLA for receptor you can look at
the spinal fluid patients at their first
event and see that they have more
b-cells and you would expect and you can
see that if you look at those B cells
for markers of activation there are a
variety of markers that show that
they're active they're not they're
passively responding just it's a local
inflammation but they may be playing an
active role as you move into clinically
definite multiple sclerosis so-called
relapse permitting stage there's a
variety of data sets to suggest B cells
play a critical role we're going to talk
about all go clonal bands what they are
and how they're related to multiple
sclerosis and you're going to see that
the over one
majority of patients with multiple
sclerosis are absolutely are virus
positive and there's a variety of
changes in CSF profiles that suggests
b-cells play an incredible role in the
pathogenesis of MS and we're going to
review data from MS patients on if you
deplete those b-cells does it make a
difference to the course of the disease
finally within the progressive stages of
disease there's pathologic data suggests
that b-cells are playing at driving
wrong so let's take a few these pieces
of circumstantial evidence and see what
the data is to convince you that b-cells
are a critical portion of multiple
sclerosis so I'll go clonal basil's so
all the clonal bands is a test that's
been around for 50 years it was put into
use in the 1960s and basically is a
measure of intrathecal synthesis of
antibodies what does that mean so we
take a person's serum and we take a
person's CSF and what we're supposed to
do is isolate out IgG molecules and then
subject those molecules to isoelectric
focusing to get these distinct
presumably clonal bands of antibody
production and indeed what has been seen
in a large number of MS patients is
there is a pattern of bands in the
spinal fluid that we don't see in the
serum so for years this was considered
one of the gold standard tests of the
biology of NS that we could see a
pattern of inflammation within MS
patients that we didn't see in others
the problem is the sensitivity and
specificity is not where we want it to
be it turns out due to this being a
qualitative test not a quantitative test
that the sensitivity is extremely
lacking when in a real-world scenario
and the specificity is also not where we
want it to be a lot of different
conditions that can affect the central
nervous system can give you all the good
little bands so it's not a specific test
of multiple sclerosis it's a specific
test of seeing intrathecal synthesis of
antibodies and unfortunately there are a
lot of different conditions that can do
that but this is today been our only
biologic test of autoimmunity relative
to multiple sclerosis if we look at
progressive patients one of the most
exciting features that we've seen in the
last ten years is the revelation that
you can develop follicular structures
kind of small leaf nodes within the
brain and the meninges of multiple
sclerosis patients
indeed UCB sells playing a critical role
in the formation of these follicles so
pathologically what we're seeing is over
time MS patients set up an autoimmune
profile
histologically that implicates B cell
biology is playing an integral role to
the pathogenesis of this disease these
Falcons also may explain why some people
go on to secondary progressive disease
and have ongoing inflammation
despite therapies directed at the
peripheral immune system that seem to do
a good job if there is a
compartmentalised in autoimmune system
within the CNS we may not necessarily be
able to reach that with therapeutics
peripherally finally let's ask the
question if b-cells are so important to
this disease what happens if I wipe out
your b-cells and indeed there have been
a number of trials looking at the drug
rituximab which is not fda-approved for
multiple sclerosis these were approved
trials that were blinded and placebo
controlled and indeed after infusion
with rituximab which is an anti cd20
molecule leading to B cell depletion
within patients in those patients did it
dramatically better and as seen here on
the graph what happened was these
patients about a hundred of them were
followed over time with serial MRIs to
look for the appearance of new lesions
and in patients who had not been treated
they went on to have new lesions over
time as you would expect in multiple
sclerosis but for those who were treated
with rituximab the disease activity was
basically suppressed and so if you take
out the B cells it looks like you can
change the course of the disease so we
have biologic although not sensitive or
specific data from spinal fluid looking
at antibody production we have
pathologic data looking at meninges and
brain disease for patients with multiple
sclerosis and we have interventional
data from drug studies such as rituximab
to kind of prove the point that b-cells
are incredibly important in the
pathogenesis of this disease but what
are they doing so let's shift gears a
little bit for multiple sclerosis and
the pathology behind it to be cell
biology so these cells undergo both T
cell dependent and independent
activation so there is a way to turn on
a visa without needing an auto
active t-cell and ultimately with the
appropriate antigen present you're going
to get antibody production that's the
ultimate purpose of b-cells as far as we
know they do function as antigen
presenting cells to t-cells but really
the effector portion of b-cells is to
produce antibodies and how does a human
being with only 30,000 genes create an
antibody repertoire that needs to cover
billions of potential antigens the way
it does that is through a series of
biological ends with both germline and
somatic hypermutation so we have a
germline genome for the B cell antibody
chains but they undergo rearrangement
the so called vdj rearrangement and this
creates a certain amount of diversity
and if you do that combinatorial math
with a number of the genes D genes and J
jeans we have you can get a certain
number of antibodies but that is far
than enough for us to be able to attack
all the different pathogens and antigens
that may come into our lives
heads within each of these families and
we're going to talk about the variable
region you're you have areas that can
mutate and within them you have those
heightened within the variable regions
both heavy and light change the light
chains that can recombine to give you
more diversity so there are a lot of
ways that b-cells create the diversity
to recognize different antigens so what
happens relative to the genetics and the
ultimate of effector functions of the
b-cells so you have a mature b-cell with
antibody expressed on its surface that
binds an antigen and it may bind the
antigen more or less loosely than one of
its sister b-cells based on the affinity
of the antigen for the antibody you got
what's called affinity maturation in
clonal expansion there is a selection
for B cells that have tighter binding to
antigen and this selection occurs based
on mutations that occur within the
variable regions of the B cells so as
with each successive b-cells you get a
little mutation that body's a little
tighter it may be selected more or less
and ultimately you form two populations
of cells a memory B cell which can
reactivate in the future act as antigen
presentation and secrete cytokines to
augment inflammation and attract t-cells
to the point of inflammation or you
create plasma cells or plasma blasts
which are basically major antibody
producers and as you track in all ago
clonal bands what we think are saying
are the specific clonal antibodies but
what you're missing is what's happening
behind it and that is the b-cell
selection over time so the affinity and
avidity are really driven in the
variable regions and a scene here of an
antibody you have a heavy chain in a
light chain the variable have a change
in the variable light chain and it's
it's variable heavy chain that drives
that binding so if you take detailed
sequencing from memory b-cells you
basically have the instruction manual
for the antibody at producing so there
are a variety of ways to characterize
the immune response of b-cells what we
have done historically is just take the
antibodies and see what antigen they
bind to these are laborious dirty
sometimes hard to reproduce experiments
because in different conditions
antibodies may bind in different ways
but in theory each clonal and in
practice in reality each clonal B cell
is responsible for one of those
antibodies so if you take the genetic
code of that b-cell you have basically
isolated at the genetic level a single
antibody and you can start to separate
out the biology instead of taking pools
of antibody that may have wildly
different characteristics of binding and
ultimately wildly different biologies so
the hypothesis that was generated by
Nancy Munson here at UT Southwestern was
that just as an antigen driven disease
can have a ceará status do you or don't
you have antibodies associated with it
an antigen driven disease such as
multiple sclerosis should have a unique
B cell genome associated with it so
instead of measuring the antibodies the
immune response you can measure the
b-cell genome in a much more precise way
in a much more granular fashion in order
to document what the biology is and
track the disease over time so indeed
that's what Nancy started working on
years ago here you
and what she found was a unique
mutational signature in B cells derived
from spinal fluid of multiple sclerosis
patients so she found as shown
graphically here compared to healthy
donors that certain codons within the
variable regions of the antibodies of
the D cell antibody production genome
had more mutations then then than what
we saw in healthy donors so healthy
donors there's a spread of mutations
you're you're acting against a variety
of different antigens you're on the
prowl but as you get the B cells
involved in multiple sclerosis they own
in on certain codons to mutate and what
she developed was a scoring system so
spinal fluid was obtained for multiple
sclerosis multiple sclerosis patients
via via lumbar puncture we do this all
the time clinically it's the test we do
for all ago clonal bands a cell pellet
was isolated so you take out all the
cells from that fluid and then you use
flow cytometry to separate out the B
cells and what Nancy did in her lab was
separate out the B cells into single
cells in a 96-well plate then you go in
at the single cell level isolate the DNA
and then do sequencing and you can look
at the variable regions of the heavy
chains and compare them to databases and
control sequences and see if there are
mutations in a certain pattern and what
Nancy saw with this single cell PCR
Sanger sequencing method was shown here
among patients with multiple sclerosis
or even patients with those clinically
isolated syndromes as first events there
was a higher mutational rate in certain
codons compared to other neurologic
diseases or healthy controls so indeed
MS patients seem to accumulate
abnormalities within certain parts of
the genome in a way different than other
patients when we looked at patients who
had confirmed multiple sclerosis their
score and there's a mathematical
algorithm you can use to create the
score counting up those mutations seemed
comparable to individuals who had just a
single event meaning this biology can be
quantified early in the course of the
disease
one concern was would patients have to
have multiple events and accumulate
these B cells over time you
order to see that they were mutating in
a given fashion but in the patients even
at their first event of multiple
sclerosis at scores that were in line
with what we saw a full-blown MS this
seems to be an early prevalent change
within the B cell biology of multiple
sclerosis patients so when we go back to
Nancy's original data which looked at
CSF derive B cells single cell PCRs one
of the questions that comes up is is
this score or being driven by mutations
or is it being driven just by a certain
prevalence of genes meaning if patients
have rearranged to have certain heavy
chains in their B cell repertoire are we
really just counting those codons and
not necessarily the mutations so she
underwent a series of experiments to
look at this question and indeed there
is over representation of certain
photons within the scoring system of
this antibody gene signatures score and
when you take these codons out it
changes the score in a significant way
so the 431 439 and 459
codons seem to be driving the AGF score
that we see invasions and if this was
the case it may or may not have as much
biologic importance and it may not be
the mutations it may just be the codon
frequency but when they looked at the
representation of these codons in ms and
and the control populations the other
patients we found that those photons
were expressed basically equally so
indeed the AES score is not being driven
by merely the expression of these codons
in the rearrangements but by the hyper
mutations that are occurring within
these codons so it seems to be that what
Nancy's lab has seen is a true biologic
signature and not just a mathematical
anomaly based on codon representation so
if you look at the the so-called
antibody gene signature score by Sanger
sequencing you see that there's a
pattern of somatic hypermutation that
seem to be both sensitive and specific
for a marker of multiple sclerosis even
early in the course of disease but to be
honest do
single cell PC ours is not a very
clinically viable thing that I could do
in at my MS practice it's a huge
endeavor in terms of labor that's
involved and is not very easy to access
from bent from bedside to bench and so
in order to make this discovery a more
clinically meaningful test you'd have to
develop a new method for identifying
sequence patterns from whole cell
collections not single cells so now you
have to be able to take the whole batch
sequence everything at once but then
sort out whether or not that mutational
frequency is there and indeed in
partnerships with Nancy collaborators
and team at Dietetics the move went to
next-generation sequencing so it what's
shown here is taking the samples again
that were looked at in terms of
single-cell PCRs but now taking whole
cell rooms using next-generation
sequencing off that whole population and
showing that you can tease out the same
antibody gene signatures for so it is
possible in a much more robust fashion
and a platform that's easier to
transport out of the bench and closer to
the bedside a way to fish out these
sequences and so technologically this is
important and is actually the basis of
an ongoing clinical trial so the
large-scale clinical trial is a
multicenter trial it's nationwide
recruiting over 250 patients to do
next-generation sequencing and determine
on a large scale can this signature be
recreated so seeing a signature seeing
that hyper mutation pattern is great it
is will be one of the first advances in
understand the biology of events in a
long time that's clinically useful
possibly from a testing point of view
but really from the scientific point of
view the next question is what's the
functional impact
what are these sequences producing what
are the antibodies doing from these
hypermutated b-cells that seem to be
unique to multiple sclerosis patients so
what
Nancy's lab did was since we had the DNA
from single cells you can generate
recombinant antibodies pure recombinant
antibodies produced based on the genetic
code when we've taken the antibodies
from the CSF and multiple scripts
patience it's a dirty group of
antibodies a truth that can stay in all
sorts of things and you never know the
relative prevalence of one antibody
versus another but by taking antibodies
we confidently designed at a single
cellular level you can start to
understand pathogenesis of the disease
in a very different way so in a first
set of experiments what the Munson lab
did was look at mouse brain tissue using
no antibody negative control and a
positive control that was generously
provided by Betty diamonds lat Nancy
Munson in the top of the screen and then
a series of single recombinant
antibodies in the bottom of the screen
showing that indeed these antibodies
weren't just an epiphenomenon floating
around these b-cells were in an
epiphenomenon they were producing
antibodies that bind to tissue this was
the first pass looking at it when a
deeper die was taken looking again at
mouse brain what they found was there
were antibodies that would bind to both
the cortex and the white matter now
remember back in the eighteen sixties
even John Martine char Coto indicated
that this is not just a white matter
disease there's a gray matter disease
and yet we had a very difficult time
understanding the immunological
pathogenesis of something that is
supposed to have myelin as the antigenic
target all of a sudden having all this
grey matter disease and here we're
finding from actual MS patients that
they have b-cells producing antibodies
that uniquely stained cortical
structures so using immunohistochemistry
the antibodies found at least in this
one patient seemed to bind to neurons
these weren't finding to Milan or
oligodendrocytes these are actually
binding to neuronal cell bodies not
necessarily what's expected in multiple
sclerosis so these were the early stabs
at looking at the refirming antibodies
from their doctor Munson's lab has gone
further to look at the transition from
mouse to human brain and to expand the
number of recombinant antibodies that
are being screened in this fashion and
basically what you can see in each of
these panels with controls being across
the top of both the mouse and the human
brain and the research antibody is being
below that there are unique stained
patterns from patients who present with
a variety of different to myelinating
conditions who go on to have multiple
sclerosis so they may bind in some
patterns with one patient and in
different patterns with another so they
seem to be unique to the patient from
which they come if we do again
immunohistochemistry we can see that
there are patterns of standing where you
are predominantly neuronal and staining
where it is astra cynic and i want to
dive deeper into this with the next
slide so over these couple slides you're
going to see immunohistochemistry
looking at different cell populations
within the brain noted here first is
stains with a neuronal marker which you
see which is the red dye and then there
were combinate antibodies from five
distinct patients labeled with a green
fluorescent protein and then the overlay
and what you'll see in the top panel is
there seems to be a very clear overlay
between the recombinant antibody and the
neuronal stain suggesting that this
patient's antibody was an anti neuronal
antibody of some kind but as you move
lower there is a lack of overlap if you
look at a jl0 one which is just a code
for a patient from which the antibody
came from to keep it all blinded this
patient doesn't see this antibody
doesn't seem to find two neurons at all
but if you switch the stain and this is
true both for mouse and human and the
reproducibility from Mouse to human has
been quite good if you switch to an
astro cynic marker in this case GF ap
that first patient that had the binding
that Co associated with new n the
pattern doesn't overlap but when you
move down to a jl a one and some of the
others indeed there is an overlap just
some patients or at least some were
coming in antibodies for patient's have
a strong binding profile for astra
siddik markers and other patients have
antibodies or I should say other
antibodies from different nations have
strong anti neuronal binding properties
this disease mirthless Prosis was a
white matter demyelinating disease
described 150 years ago over the last 40
years we thought of it as an autoimmune
reaction against Milan and
we are with Munson labid at Southwestern
identifying recombinant antibodies from
a selected group of b-cells an
over-represented population of these
cells within these multiple sclerosis
patients that is uniquely staining non
myelin damage ins and may be very
important for the pathogenesis of the
disease
beyond the relapsing stages that we so
commonly see in the clinic fascinating
was the staining of certain antibodies
to cells that expressed nestin and this
was shown both with immunohistochemistry
as well as looking at flow cytometry
data and these neuronal progenitor cells
which are nest and positive were bound
by certain recombinant antibodies from
patients thus it may not even just be
the mature cells that are affected by
anti normal antibodies or anti a
specific antibodies but this disease may
have an autoimmune profile that affects
progenitor cells even early in the
course of disease which may make a
difference for people's repair
mechanisms and recovery mechanisms if
not the progressive stage of this
disease it's an intriguing finding that
has not been previously described
so the antibody staining patterns fall
into different categories and I've only
shown you a few of them here as the work
continues to go on but the recombinant
antibodies which are generated from D
cell clones identified exclusively in MS
patients have binding patterns so a
variety of cells above mouths and human
tissues there been over 30 clones that
have been created and the staining
patterns are being analyzed and
correlated with clinical data remember
that list of symptoms at the beginning
of the talk relative to multiple
sclerosis fatigue pain cognition
depression a variety of vague cerebral
network symptoms not the weakness from
hitting a motor track one of the things
we're doing is sorting out will these
different staining patterns sustaining
of neurons versus astrocytes etc explain
some of the different symptoms that we
have and so it is important for us to
continue looking at the clinical
correlations with this
so in conclusion basically these B cells
from patients with multiple sclerosis
have a unique signature relative to
their somatic hypermutation pattern
within the vh4 region the areas of hyper
mutation can be used to distinguish
multiple sclerosis from patients without
multiple sclerosis and even in early
patients the so-called clinically
isolated syndrome visions we see this
pattern and finally when we look at the
antibodies that are produced from these
patients it makes a difference in terms
of our thinking the pathogenesis they
have a very unique binding pattern and
that binding pattern may have clinical
implications so the future directions
where we plan to go with this is that
there we're going to better define the
regions with hypermutation we're going
to look at the clinically the clinical
value of this as a diagnostic test and
that's the ongoing clinical trial can we
have a better way to differentiate
multiple sclerosis from not based on
these patterns of hypermutation
and we're going to look at the antigenic
targets of these antibodies this work
has been a collaborative work amongst a
number of people represented here in
multiple different university labs and
associations the Munson lab which has
led the team Nancy Munson and her group
we have an active repository staff and
clinical Enterprise here at UT
Southwestern a bioinformatics core and
then there have been collaborations at
different universities identified here
of which a lot of this work could not be
done we do always thank the patients
who've consented to take part in
research
none of this could happen without them
and the funding that went into this was
both at the NIH level the National
Multiple Sclerosis Society level and
daya genex which has funded some of the
work within the Munson lot so with that
in mind I'm happy to answer any
questions as you know within the
question and answer portion on the web
you can type in the questions and we'll
take them I'll deal with the first ones
that have come up so the first question
I'm being asked is how effective is the
role of neuropsychological
rehabilitation and MS considering its
progressive nature of deterioration and
this gets to the issue of cognitive
decline in MS one of the biggest issues
that got ignored for 50 years in MS was
the impact it has on cognition and
indeed if you look at easily half or
two-thirds of our patients with multiple
sclerosis they have some pattern of
cognitive dysfunction we have just
started to look at the role of cognitive
rehabilitation can we train people to
have better cognition and indeed you can
there is very limited data on the
longevity of the effect within multiple
sclerosis so we we don't know if you get
a benefit from neuropsychological
rehabilitation will it be a sustained
benefit and so it's a it's a good
question I'm not sure we know the answer
yet but it's still something we
routinely recommend if patients do have
cognitive dysfunction the next question
I'm being asked is do we see any
interaction between T and B cells in
your model so we know that B cells act
as engine presenter cells to T cells and
that T cells can drive B cell responses
visto repertoire through cytokine
production and activation with
transition of b-cells
from mature B cells into plasma blaster
memory cells we have not taken the
clonal populations of these cells as of
yet from these patients in this set of
experiments to look at T cell
interactions we know they exist they
exist and and that's been shown in
multiple sclerosis before we don't know
if the cells that have unique hybrid
mutation patterns have a differential
response to T cells we wouldn't
necessarily expect them to but it's an
area of study that is worthy of being
looked at so there's a a comment
indicating or a question I should say
they asked me why haven't we matured a
whole lot more past our close definition
of MS decades ago and I'd say over a
century ago
so jean-martin charcot described
multiple sclerosis in 1868 and we're
still describing it in a similar fashion
in 2014 in some respects that's a little
scary but it's actually work like what
Nancy's done in others that I think are
going to finally start to dissect this
out
and it actually summarizes the problem
we lump a lot of people with a certain
phenotype whether it's a clinical
phenotype and MRI phenotype or a
pathologic phenotype into one diagnosis
they're not one diagnosis there are
different biologies at play but we've
never had a sensitive measured again at
the underlying biology well looking at
the antibody profiles the antibody genes
signature profiles does is gives us a
much cleaner way of separating out the
immune system molecularly to try and
decide what's happening within our
patients and so I think this combined
with other research may hopefully get us
a little further away from the way you
Charcot described things and hopefully
in a better place for our patients so
the next question is in relation to the
role of B cells in the immune of
pathology of MS
if D cell activation in the form of algo
clintonb and production is the most is
the most consistent intelligent finding
in patients with MS what predicts
markers of B cell activation within the
CSF of patients with MS so we don't know
what predicts B cell activation within
CSF of MS patients we just know that
they are there they're there early and
they seem to be a driver of the disease
and so presumably it's whatever they're
relating to antigenically
which drives their reaction since 1942
the question goes on when these algo
clonal bands were first described by
cobot which is correct by knowing that
these cells have paradoxical roles in
autoimmunity exerting both pathogenic
and protective effects what have been
the achievements of scientists like you
be like I'm for Munson in the targeting
of different antigens so the author here
brings up a excellent point that not all
antibodies are batting bodies there are
some V cell responses which are helpful
and protective in autoimmunity and
indeed we have not sorted that out
within this forward there is ample
evidence though to say at least for
relapse permitting disease and to some
degree for a progressive disease that
these B cells play a pathogenic role if
you go back to the evidence of
correlation of follicles with pression
of the usefulness of depleting B cells
at suppressing relapses it seems as
though the B cells are more harmful than
helpful
although
I'm sure that's not globally true for
all the b-cells they're sorting out in
an antigenic fashion what the antibodies
are doing is critically important that
we're working on that as we speak and we
have questions about partnerships and
collaborations we do we're always
looking for collaborations relative to
this work and by all means we encourage
you to reach out to us we work with a
wide variety of groups as you can see
from the slides here there's a question
on the role of microglial cells in ms
progression so great question
remember I made mention of the notion on
that busy slide with different parts of
the immune system in the brain -
adaptive and innate immunity and within
adaptive immunity the T and B cells
obviously there has been a whole host of
work but the innate immune system within
multiple sclerosis is something that has
not gotten the level of attention that
it deserves and this includes suppose
the periphery at the dendritic cell
level where we know that there are
changes in function relative to
dendritic cells of multiple sclerosis
patients and the innate immune system of
the brain the microglia or the so called
macrophages of the brain we know that
there is some evidence of exaggerated
microglial activation in multiple
sclerosis and this may correlate with
progressive disease there are new
imaging studies based imaging studies as
well as basic biology studies that look
at the role of microglia and MS and
indeed I think you're going to see an
evolving story on microglial activation
of multiple sclerosis that may have new
therapeutic targets now the interplay
between the innate and the adaptive
immune system is also an area
significant interest because they talk
to each other the innate immune system
of microglia can activate B cells within
the adaptive immune system and vice
versa so there's a question about
alternative medicines and beneficial
effects for treating multiple sclerosis
this is a completely underserved area
within ms we know that there are a
variety of ways patients can manage
their symptoms as well as their disease
the alternative medicine quote unquote
the non-fda-approved I should say or
allistic approach to treating MS that's
gotten the most
supportive evidence for it is the data
regarding vitamin D there is data to say
that if your vitamin D deficient you
have a dramatically increased risk of
developing multiple sclerosis and
individuals who are vitamin D deficient
and have them as probably have more
relapses at a more progressive course
when supplemented there is some data
suggests that vitamin D supplementation
and driving a person's vitamin D level
to higher rates in the blood so not the
dose you take but how much do we
actually get into your body can drive
down attack rates in multiple sclerosis
presumably this is occurring because of
effects on the immune system although
that has not been conclusively proven we
know that B cells respond to vitamin D
levels in a variety of different ways
and when it comes to the holistic or
alternative medicine this is the one
that probably has the most data
supporting its use the next question is
what is the most effective treatment
considering B cell as the main player
based on my view so the most effective
treatment of ultimate roses I don't
think we know the answer of that in
head-to-head trial data so we have not
taken all the fda-approved or even non
approved drugs and put them into a
head-to-head comparative effectiveness
trial it's not been done the drugs that
seem to from their independent trial
data have the most potent impact on the
disease from the fda-approved drugs
nate'll is an AB probably has the best
data thing Lola mod and dimethyl
fumarate have extremely good data and
it's worth noting all of these drugs
have impacts on b-cell function or
migration in terms of trials that may
not have led to FDA approval or been
submitted for FDA approval for example
rituximab has not been submitted for FDA
approval or review it was pretty
profound effects on the disease and so I
think there's ample evidence to say that
drugs that have some impact on B cell
biology makes a big difference in terms
of the disease so there's a great
question here on how do we know that
this B cell response is
driven by the t-cell activity and you're
you're right we cannot prove the chicken
and egg issue between which comes first
and autoreactive t-cell or an auto
reactive b-cell really what we can do is
do subtraction studies and say well why
don't we take the b-cell component out
what happens to the disease with the
t-cell component out and as we just
discussed with the last question b-cell
targeted therapies make a huge
difference now the next logical question
is well are we just impacting their
antigen presenting cell functions and we
don't know the answer that but it is a
critical player in the disease
pathogenesis it would be nice to know
which came first t-cell are b-cell I'm
not sure we're going to be able to
answer that at least anytime soon so
there's a question here on whether or
not we used any antibodies specific to
mutant proteins and are we able to see
differences in expression between normal
and mutant protein expression using
immunohistochemistry the answer is no we
haven't looked at at specific mutant
proteins we've done this from the
antibody side not the antigen side so
we're not screening for the antibodies
which has been the classical approach to
b-cell studies and multiple sclerosis
for the last 30 years you take the
antibodies put them on a dish and see
what what antigens get stained and you
have an array of antigens when the a C's
lab at dr. Munson's lab has done is
going the other way which is let's make
the antibodies in a clonal manner make
it a pure batch of the antibody and
start hunting for what antigen they bind
to in their native state and that's the
work that's going on now as you saw we
have a variety different cellular
targets but we're starting to work on
what are the underlying antigens within
the cellular targets and that work is
early going one of the parts of that
work is to also sort out with inpatients
and between patients are there different
patterns of staining so it would be
interesting to know that if some
patients are more neuronal where some
patient's are more astra CITIC or some
are oligodendrocytes and do those have
clinical
and as we sort out those different areas
drilling down the specific antigens
obviously will be incredibly important
so I think this will be our last
question
I mentioned that most MS patients test
positive for epstein-barr
are there other diseases where the
majority of patients that's positive for
a particular virus and is there an
ongoing effort to investigate if a
causal causal relationship exists so a
variety of chronic conditions and
autoimmune diseases have been looking
for associated viruses for a year the
data for epstein-barr and multiple
sclerosis is probably the strongest out
of any of the autoimmune diseases in a
virus this one probably has the
strongest Association and so it's
something that receives a lot of
attention so I appreciate everybody's
attention and hope you have a great rest
of the conference